Chris waters here with a gamespot news
update Blizzard has revealed the next
world of warcraft expansion lee jin wow
the expansion will add a new continent
called broken Isles it's never been
playable in World of Warcraft before but
was referenced in Warcraft freak what's
more Legion raises World of Warcraft's
level cap to 110 and introduces new
dungeons raids and artifact weapons but
the biggest announcement was the new
demon hunter hero class this melee
focused class can specializes either DPS
or tank but given the role of demon
hunters in Warcraft lore buzzard felt
that a healer spec wouldn't quite fit
demon hunters will be able to
metamorphosize into fell forms to be
able to hit harder and take more
punishment this is the first expansion
since 2014's warlords of Draenor world
of warcraft subscribers have been
slipping at a quick rate losing 1.5
million subscribers in the last three
months this expansion will likely help
boost those numbers at least for a short
amount of time a beta is expected later
this year meaning we can probably expect
the actual expansion to launch sometime
early in 2016 expect more details about
Legion at blizzcon this November and for
more news from gamescom stay tuned to
gamespot com splash news